[Musique]
tout est prêt à voir chez une tonne le
président crom s'apprête à prononcer son
deuxième discours sur l'état de l'union
un discours reporté d'une semaine en
raison de l'impasse budgétaire qui a
paralysé le gouvernement pendant 35
jours
mesdames messieurs bonsoir bienvenue à
cette émission spéciale c'est dans un
contexte de division que dans notre
homme va s'adresser aux deux chambres du
congrès réunies dans une même salle la
trêve budgétaire prend fin dans dix
jours à washington et le financement du
fameux mur continue de déchirer
démocrates et républicains avec moi pour
cette émission spéciale karine brémond
professeur agrégé à l'école de politique
appliquée de l'université de sherbrooke
notre encadrement soit john parisella
professeur invité au centre d'études et
de recherches internationales de ce
grand soir devant soi et moi j'ai une
toute notre correspondant christian
latreille bonsoir j'ai commencé avec
vous parce que toujours un moment
solennel attendu peut-être
particulièrement cette année christian
parce que le président trump a déjà tant
de la volonté de 9,6 paul audi pour être
invité à la chambre des représentants
dans un contexte de très grande tension
mais déjà certains extraits filtres
comme le veut la tradition les spots
attali les meilleurs extraits qu'est ce
qu'on en sait maintenant mais certains
disent même que monsieur tube a mis fin
à la fermeture partielle du gouvernement
justement pour être en mesure de
respecter cette tradition et d'avoir
l'occasion de ce s'adresser à des
millions d'américains qui vont l'écouter
ce soir et vous avez raison il ya
quelques extraits qui ont commencé à
filtrer du discours de monsieur chambre
prévoit un discours d'environ 45 minutes
l'année dernière ça avait été 80 minutes
on verra bien de quelle manière et à
quel mérite monsieur jobs lire à ce
discours mais ce que l'on peut voir
jusqu'à maintenant anne marie ces crimes
se trempe de tenter un peu comme il
l'avait fait d'ailleurs l'année dernière
il veut tenter eu le tendre la main aux
américains tendre la main aux démocrates
également et se faire en sorte en
quelque sorte un peu lus ni unir il veut
unir si c'est ce qui le mentionne dans
les lignes qui nous ont été rendus
disponibles
il veut faire en sorte de pensée les
vieilles blessures
de mettre fin aux vieilles querelles qui
divisent la classe politique américaine
à washington
il mentionne également bon il revient
sur ses sur ses réussites entre autres
sa réforme de la justice criminelle ou
aux états unis
il veut également s'attaquer aux prix
des médicaments qui coûte très très cher
aux américains est un des pays où les
médicaments coûtent coûte le plus cher
il sera question des infrastructures
aussi questions d'immigration il veut
absolument que ce problème soit réglé
afin que de passer à autre chose on sait
que plusieurs présidents se sont cassé
les dents au cours des dernières
générations à tenter de régler le
problème de l'immigration et bien sûr
c'est pas écrit dans les lignes du corps
ont été rendus publics jusqu'à
maintenant mais c'est certainement
monsieur de chambre va passer le message
de façon très claire qu'il veut ce mur
il y tient absolument
de quelle manière il va s'y prendre on
verra bien mais là la grande différence
ce soir c'est que le congrès est
maintenant le contrôle du congrès
maintenant partager les démocrates
contrôlent la chambre et vous verrez
juste derrière son épaule
non pas un mais bien anticipé l'oci qui
pour la deuxième fois devient le leader
de la chambre est intéressant de lire le
langage corporel de tous et chacun ce
soir pour voir un peu comment ça va se
passer
alors d'autres mondes du congrès arrive
en tête du cabinet on voit mal un pelosi
pendant qu'on nous parlait à côté du
vice-président peines et christian le
discours de monsieur chambre l'année
dernière c'était 5839 mots mais ça s'est
terminé à 22h17 et monsieur vraiment
avant 6824 c'était beaucoup plus long qu
annoncée on va voir si ça sera le cas ce
soir toute façon on est là pour le
couvrir intégralement ses discours
surveiller à quel moment monsieur chrome
sera applaudi sur quel thème s'il va
réussir à faire à se faire applaudir par
les démocrates puis pendant que vous
nous parlez christ et on a vu l'arrivée
de madame jobs entouré des invités de la
maison blanche
je vois qu'on en dise un petit mot là
dessus a écrit sans si vous voulez bien
avant de continuer sur l'importance du
discours parce que on veut toujours
passer des messages à travers les
invitations que l'on fait à certaines
personnes qui ont marqué l'actualité
l'actualité américaine ouais d'un côté
comme de l'autre d'ailleurs les
démocrates ont le droit à leur
éviter à leurs invités les républicains
le président droit s'est invitée
également monsieur thiam qui a invité
une dénommée alice qui elle a passé de
nombreuses années en prison pour une
transaction de drogue crime sans
violence et on sait que la réforme qui
est le fruit d'une collaboration entre
démocrates et républicains cette réforme
sur la justice criminelle aux états unis
va faire en sorte que ce genre de
situations se produisent beaucoup moins
souvent les démocrates de leur côté ont
invités cette dame rappelez vous lorsque
jeff flake avait été apostrophé ou du
moins interpellé en prenant l'ascenseur
au moment au brut car venant était
devant le sénat où on étudiait sa
candidature et bien cette femme avait
avait avait vraiment eu les messieurs
flec en disant vous devez absolument
refuser ce poste à monsieur kavanagh et
bien cette personne sera là elle était
l'invitée de madame occasion carts cette
nouvelle des matelas qui qui brassent
beaucoup en ce moment aux achats pendant
que vous ne parlez de john peut-être
vous pouvez la conversation on voit la
patte de la grande patronne de la ciat
est contredit par monsieur crème et
monsieur cause qui était allié à la noix
et le plus dense du dr nikki et le
département de détergents sociale je me
suis tu recules qui étaient des équipes
accueillera par intérim se sont produits
ces le ça va nous permettre de subir qui
va être le nouveau procureur général lui
est controversée monsieur woodcock qui
avait fait des propres comptes
la requête monsieur mario donkey
surveillance et par là même l objet de
ce pays n'a pas là la chambre des
représentants
pour d'autres questions ils veulent le
mettre sur la défensive parce qu'ils ont
toutes parts que ça soit lui ou ou
barkat molveau des positions l'apa qui
choisissent de ne pas remettre le
rapport intégral et c'est à ce moment là
il y avait beaucoup d'émotion qui
s'inquiètent à semaine d'aidé publique
et ses catastrophes y en a qui disent
l'ultime on scande à ce qu'il dévoile
pomme se salive locaux mais monsieur de
chambre dans son entrevue cbs en fait
semaine juste avant ce propos que la
matinée avait laissé entendre il n'était
pas certain en tout cas c'est tout oui
mais c'est pas lui qui va décider
c'est pour ça que c'est important savoir
ce que je suis beau faire on peut
imaginer que certains membres du congrès
démocrate ou même dans l'équipe de mon
lait on pourrait peut-être faire des
fuites sur ce rapport si jamais il
devait être lu et je pense que la
promenade lui est rendu au point que
c'était l'incontournable je pense que
les gens s'attendent a surpris puis
c'est que c'est quand même une enquête
qui dure depuis près de deux ans et elle
se sent bla est assez méthodique dans la
façon qu'il a failli quand même des
accusations des gens qui ont plaidé
coupable puis à des arrestations puis à
des enquêtes qui sont à d'autres niveaux
le district sud de new york fait des
enquêtes ou s'y est employé le congrès
qui vont commencer des enquêtes sur de
la part des poux de monsieur train alors
la caméra se fait que ce jour sur madame
sur madame chambre qui a invité d'autres
personnes est en fête
christian garçons jouent à trump et qui
est là un jeune garçon parce qu'il est
intimidé semble-t-il parce qu'il est un
troll mais il produit une parente il
existe un lien avec la campagne de
contre les cyber intimidation madame
chan on peut penser que le président
s'approche dans quelques quelques
minutes le parlement
je pense qu'on fait l'appel du président
location dans la peau
je sais l'importance du disque au
constructeur je pense que c'est un
discours très importants à la mairie
pour monsieur chambre parce que ils
savent quand même une période difficile
ce que vient de lui faire vivre nancy
pelosi en lui refusant le financement
sont mûrs et surtout en le désinvité en
lui refusant l'accès au congrès pour ce
fameux discours sur l'état de l'union
ça a été extrêmement difficile pour le
surprendre
je pense que c'est rarement arrivé qu'un
président se fasse refuser un discours
sur l'état de l'union et il a perdu
cette bataille contre madame qu'elle
aussi est ce soit bien ce sera
l'occasion comme sous le charme de se
reprendre et de réitérer c'est sa
volonté de vouloir unir les américains
on sait que l'année dernière ça n'a pas
duré tellement longtemps mais ce ne
serait pas le genre de président où
c'est le genre de personnalité qui
facilement va unir les américains ils
l'utilisent plutôt et les divisent
politiquement les etats-unis n'ont
jamais été aussi divisés comme ceux ci
étaient il ya des tamis des gens qui
n'osent même plus parler de politique
alors comment est ce que monsieur
chambre va faire pour tenter d'unir ce
pays qui n'a jamais été aussi la
écartelée donc ce sera ce serait
intéressant de le suivre mais il ya
certainement des terrains d'entente vous
savez comme les infrastructures le prix
des élites des médicaments ce sont ce
sont des sujets ce sont des items sur
lesquels il peut s'entendre avec avec
les démocrates
alors on verra la collaboration qui
naîtra entre madame qui elle aussi ne
naîtra pas entre madame pelletier et
monsieur tremblay ce soir ce sera
l'occasion de voir aussi et ça c'est
important comment il va souligner
également la présence de madame paule
aussi parce qu'en 2007 george bush avait
eu la délicatesse avait été très
gentleman en disant je suis très honorée
pour la première fois de dire madame
spicules madame la leader alors je pense
que les yeux seront rivés sur notre
homme se soit pour voir de quelle
manière il accueillera nancy paul aussi
qu' historiquement il arrive
non pas de soutien rapides ou pourquoi
il ya beaucoup de blancs malin pelosi
temps blanc et d'autres sont en de la
web en veut on veut commémorer le 100e
anniversaire du droit de vote des
américaines elle avait obtenu le droit
de vote de dures luttes et
les femmes en blanc ce soir c'est un que
ça que l'on veut souligné anne marie o
pour graines bon alors mais sa présence
imaginez qui va pas la parole d'une
semaine à l'autre voix l'écouté on va
décrypter ce discours après avec les
habits car actuellement jean par les
élèves ou un christian washington on a
quelques extrêmement de voir s'il a
durci le ton
si ce sera présidentielle si cet appel à
l'unité et crédible s'il sort ne sont
est ce on sait jamais et vous c'est des
choses qui peuvent arriver
alors monsieur peines qui est le vice
président on n'a pas marqué c'est pas
trop chaleureux quand même tester corée
où ils se sont fait la belle sans plus
le projet st 2 qui ne va pas une
réplique aussi comme indépendants je
compte facebook je crois que c'est une
bonne décision mais c'est une entaille
et on n'a pas vu beaucoup de gens qui
sont
qui ont forcé la prise de photo comme on
voit dans cette brève comme la raison
sociale et les invités se claque
les invités sont traités mexicain
mondiale témoigne non pas des thèmes
donc c'est pas nécessairement des deux
côtés des républicains à la maison
blanche jackson comics and immigrants
illégaux soir du côté de madame pelosi
des gens sinon j'ai un succès au delà de
la paralysie des transgenres également
donc alors on va écouter insultes
francky bon discours madame monsieur
respect l'écouté on se retrouve tantôt
monsieur monsieur le vice-président
membres du congrès la première dame des
etats unis
[Applaudissements]
et mes chers compatriotes le moment en
est un de potentiel illimité à mesure
que c'est un nouveau congrès je suis là
debout devant vous prêt à travailler
afin d'orchestrer des percées
historiques pour tous les américains
l'emilien de nos concitoyens elle nous
regarde nous écoute dans cette grande
assemblée espérant que nous allons
gouverner
non pas comme deux parties mais comme
une seule nation
[Applaudissements]
les priorités que j'aimerais vous
présenter ce ne sont pas des priorités
républicaines ou démocrates
ce sont les priorités du peuple
américain
beaucoup d'entre nous avons fait
campagne sur les mêmes promesses de base
à voir défendre l'emploi américain et
demandé du commerce équitable pour le
travailleur américain rebâtir et
revitaliser notre infrastructure
nationale réduire le prix des soins de
santé et des médicaments prescrits d'en
arriver à un système d'immigration qui
est sécuritaire tir légal moderne et qui
assurent la sécurité de tout un chacun
et de n'arriver une politique étrangère
qui mène nous intéresse elle en fait les
interdits amérique où tout premier plan
il ya une occasion maintenant qu'ils se
présentent à nous mais il nous faut
faire preuve de courage pour saisir
cette occasion historique qui se
présente à nous
vécu cela la victoire
ce n'est pas de gagner pour notre parti
la victoire c'est de gagner pour notre
pays
cette année l'amérique va reconnaître
deux anniversaires importants qui nous
montre la majesté de l'émission
historique de l'amérique et le pouvoir
de cet orgueil national au mois de juin
il y avait déjà 75 ans que le général
louisiane a rappelé la grande croisade
la libération par les alliés de l'europe
lors de la seconde guerre mondiale
on dit des et donc le jour dès le 6 juin
1944 15 mai le jeune américain ont sauté
du ciel et 60 mais se sont présentés par
voie maritime afin de sauver notre
civilisation de la tyrannie ici ce soir
avec nous il ya trois d'entre eux trois
de ses héros incroyable le prévenu
première classe est joseph rallye le
sergent d'état-major rhinois que et le
sergent ahmed zaïd tchèque
[Applaudissements]
jérôme m oui messieurs nous vous saluons
2009 nous célébrons également le
cinquantenaire de jeunes pilotes ont
traversé deux cent cinquante mille
milles à travers l'espace pour planter
notre drapeau sur la surface lunaire
un demi siècle plus tard on a un des
astronautes d'apollo 11 qui a planté ce
drapeau base en données parmi nous ce
soir
merci cette année les astronautes
américains vont retourner dans l'espace
sur des fusées américaines
au 20ème siècle l'amérique a sauvé la
liberté a transformé la science a
redéfini la classe moyenne
et quand on y pense il n'ya rien par
tout le monde qui peut faire concurrence
à l'amérique
aujourd'hui il nous faut faire preuve
d'audace pour ouvrir le prochain
chapitre de cette grande aventure
américaine
il nous faut en arriver à nouveau niveau
de vie pour le 21e siècle une qualité de
vie exceptionnelle pour tous nos
concitoyens et ça c'est à notre portée
mesdames et messieurs nous pouvons
rendre nos communautés plus sûres
nos familles plus forte notre culture
plus riches
notre foi plus profondes et notre classe
moyenne plus importante et plus prospère
qu'à tout moment delà du passé national
oui moi mais il nous faut rejeter les
politiques de la vengeance de la
résistance et de la rétribution est
acceptée le potentiel sans l'aimer de la
coopération du compromis et du bien
commun
week-end ensemble nous pouvons mettre
fin à des décennies d'impasse politique
nous pouvons jeter des ponts nous
pouvons penser dans simplet nous pouvons
arriver de nouvelles coalitions forger
de nouvelles solutions et libérer la
promesse extraordinaire de l'avenir
américain les décisions nous revient
il nous faut choisir entre la grandeur
et la paralysie les résultats au la
résistance la vision ou la vengeance le
progrès incroyables ou de la destruction
sans fin ce soir je vous invite de viser
la grandeur
[Applaudissements]
depuis deux ans mon gouvernement a agi
de façon urgente à une vitesse
historique afin d'affronter les
problèmes qui avaient été négligés par
des leaders des deux partis pendant de
longues décennies qu en deux ans depuis
mon élection
nous avons lancé un programme économique
sans précédent et c'est rare qu'on a vu
un tel essor économique
on ne rien vu de la sorte nous avons
créé 5,3 millions d'emplois nouveaux et
encore plus important
nous avons acheté 600 mhz et nouveaux
emplois manufacturiers
en fait chacun disait que c'était une
tâche impossible
mais le fait demeure et nous le faisons
que commencer
les salaires augmentent au rythme le
plus rapide depuis des décennies et elle
augmente
cette force salariale pour les cols
bleus et cela un rythme plus rapide
qu'on le pensait possible tout près de
cinq millions d'américains ne prennent
plus de coupons alimentaires
[Applaudissements]
l'américaine croit presque deux fois
plus vite aujourd'hui que quand j'ai
pris le pouvoir et nous sommes vus comme
étant l'économie la plus forte du monde
entier et loin devant les autres
le chômage a atteint le taux le plus
faible en 50 ans
[Applaudissements]
les afro américains les hispano
américains et les asiatiques américains
ont connu un taux de chômage le plus
faible de l'histoire de notre pays de
l'histoire de nos statistiques même
le chômage pour les américains qui
vivent avec un handicap a également
atteint un niveau tellement bas que
c'est du jamais vu
il ya plus de gens qui travaillent
aujourd'hui qu'à tout moment de
l'histoire de notre pays
157 millions de personnes au travail
nous avons fait adopter une réduction
d'impôt pour les travail pour les
familles de travailleurs ils vont
doubler le crédit d'impôt pour les
enfants
nous avons presque mis fin à la taxe sur
la succession ou la taxe sur la mort
comme on l'a souvent rappelé sur les pme
pour les ranchs et aussi pour les
exploitations agricoles de possession
familiale
nous avons éliminé le mandat individuel
très peu populaire de la politique
d'obama coeur et pour les gens qui était
gravement malade
nous avons offert des remèdes et nous
avons fait adopter et c'est très
important
le droit d'essayer le droit d'essayer
des médicaments des remèdes qui
n'avaient pas nécessairement été
homologué mon gouvernement a éliminé
plus de règlement en très peu de temps
et cela de loin en avance sur tous les
autres gouvernements que ce soit 4 vite
un cumulé des entreprises reviennent au
pays et cela c'est en foule grâce à
notre réduction historique d'un
dérèglement et le fardeau fiscal et nous
avons libéré une révolution dans le
secteur énergétique
les etats unis sont maintenant le
premier producteur de pétrole et de gaz
naturel au monde
maintenant pour la toute première fois
depuis 65 ans nous sommes un pays
exportateur d'énergie
m après 24 mois de rapides de progrès
notre économie fait l'envi du monde
entier et notre appareil militaire est
le plus puissant de la planète et de
loin et l'amérique
a marqué l'amérique de nouveau
vingt deux victoires victoire de jour en
jour congressistes l'état de notre union
et fort
[Applaudissements]
c'est tellement agréable à entendre
[Musique]
notre pays vit une effervescence et
notre économie connaît un essor comme en
tout cas c'est du jamais vu
vendredi on a annoncé qu'il y avait eu
300 4000 emplois de rajouter le mois
dernier seulement presque le double du
chiffre auquel on s'attendait
les quidams nous assistons un miracle
économique aux états unis est la seule
chose qui puisse l'arrêter
ce sont des guerres un peu ridicule la
politique ou des enquêtes partisane
ridicule
evergreen si nous voulons connaître la
paix et un programme le chef ces friches
on ne peut pas voir de la gare et des
enquêtes
cela ne fonctionne pas ainsi
oui ma fille nous faut nous unir chez
nous pour que nous puissions vaincre de
nos adversaires à l'étranger cette
nouvelle ère de coopération peut
commencer avec la confirmation des plus
de 300 nominés qui sont encore paralysés
par le sénat parfois des années
d'attentes
c'est inacceptable
seul le sénat n'a pas agi sur ces
candidatures et c'est injuste envers les
candidats est très injuste envers le
pays dans son ensemble
le temps est venu pour l'action
bipartite
croyez le ou non nous avons déjà prouvé
que cela est possible
lors du dernier congrès les deux parties
se sont rassemblés afin de faire adopter
des lois sans précédent pour régler la
crise des opiacés également une nouvelle
loi sur l'agriculture des réformes à
l'administration les anciens combattants
et après quatre décennies nous avons
fait adopter les [ __ ] habilité pour les
anciens combattants pour que nous
puissions congédie ceux qui sont
responsables de maltraitance à l'égard
de nos anciens combattants
à peine quelques semaines d'ailleurs les
deux parties se sont unis pour en
arriver à une réforme pénale sans
précédent ils ont dit que c'était
impossible qu'on réussira pas eh bien
c'est faux on a réussi
ouais si l'année dernière par
l'entremise d'amis
j'ai entendu parler d' alice johnson
aouiss des primo je t'ai vraiment imu en
alès s'est retrouvé en prison à
perpétuité
comme résultat de délits non violents
liés aux stupéfiants pendant deux
décennies
elle est devenue une pasteure en prison
à espérer d'autres à choisir une
meilleure voie elle a eu un impact très
important sur la population carcérale et
au delà des murs de cette prison
l'histoire d'alice souligner les
injustices les aimer quitté qui peuvent
exister dans la détermination des peines
et le besoin de corriger cette injustice
criante
elle a passé tout près de vingt deux ans
derrière les barreaux
et elle s'attendait à mourir en prison
angie mois de juin par décret
présidentiel
j'ai mis une fin à sa peine quand j'ai
vu sa belle-famille l'accueillir au port
de la prison alain bras c'est à pleurer
à crier à rire à l'étreindre je voyais
que j'avais agi comme sommes juste à
l'essai parmi nous ce soir et c'est une
femme incroyable et formidable alès
arros takeo alès merci de nous rappeler
que nous avons toujours le pouvoir de
façonner notre propre destin merci merci
à l'iss
inspiré par les histoires telles que
celle d'alice mon gouvernement travaille
en étroite collaboration avec les
membres des deux partis afin de signer
une nouvelle loi loi très importante
[Applaudissements]
donc changer les lois sur la
détermination des peines qui ont lésé de
façon disproportionnée la communauté
afro américaine
cette loi sur le premier par offre aux
délinquants non violents de retourner
dans la société comme les citoyens
respectueux de la loi
maintenant des étangs un peu partout
sont en train d'emboîter le pas
l'amérique est une nation qui croient en
le pouvoir des rédemptions nous avons
aussi parmi nous machete chose du
tennessee en 1996 quand il avait 30 ans
matthew a reçu une peine de 35 1 pour la
vente de stupéfiants et des délits
reliés sur les 25 ans suivi il a
complété plus de 30 cours sur la bible
est devenu un greffier juridique et a
été un mentor pour beaucoup de ses amis
en présent matin il est le premier à
avoir été libéré en vertu de cette
nouvelle loi
quand kelly si de loi sur les premiers
pas mathieu
merci matthew bienvenue chez toi
émettant républicains comme démocrates
doivent se joindre afin d'affronter une
crise nationale de toute première
urgence
le congrès a dix jours pour adopter une
loi qui pourra financer notre
gouvernement
protégez notre patrie et sécuriser notre
frontière avec le mexique cette
frontière très dangereux le temps est
venu pour le congrès de montrer au monde
qu'à l'amérique s'est engagé à mettre
fin à l'immigration illégale est de
mettre les passeurs les cartels les
narcotrafiquants les trafiquants d'êtres
humains hors du pays
au moment de vous parler de grande
caravane organisée marche vers les etats
unis vers nos frontières nous voulons
d'entendre que des villes mexicaines
afin de déplacer ces immigrants illégaux
de leurs villes et villages sont en
train de rassembler des camions et les
autocars pour les amener vers notre
frontière
là où il ya peu de protection à la
frontière moi j'ai donné l'ordre
d'envoyer 3750 soldats à la frontière
afin de se préparer pour cette
déferlante
c'est une question d'ordre moral l'état
sans loi au sud de notre frontière c'est
une menace pour le bien-être financier
les la sécurité de chaque américain
nous avons un devoir moral d'en arriver
à un système d'immigration qui protège
la vie ils les emplois de nos citoyens
cela inclut notre devoir envers des
millions des mes grains qui vivent ici
par mine aujourd'hui qui ont suivi les
règles qui ont respecté nos lois les
migrants légaux enrichissent notre
nation renforce notre société et cela de
façon multiples
à oilpé moi je veux voir arriver des
gens chez nous et cela sans les met sur
le plan quantitatif mais cela doit être
fait selon les règles selon les lois ils
doivent arriver ici légalement
ce live ce soir je vous demande de
m'aider à défendre cette frontière sud
si dangereuse
mus par l'amour et le dévouement envers
vos compatriotes envers votre pays
aucun enjeu n'illustre mieux la scission
entre la classe politique de l'est de
l'amérique et la classe ouvrière
d'amérique que l'immigration illégale
les politiciens les donateurs riches
veulent des frontières ouvertes par minc
ils vivent dans le luxe
emmuré
mais loi entre temps les américains de
la classe ouvrière doivent en payer le
lourd tribut de cette migration illégale
- d'emplois laisse à la plus bas des
écoles les hôpitaux qui croule en fait
des hôpitaux sont tellement remplis
qu'on peut même pas rentrer une
criminalité à la hausse et un filet de
sécurité sociale trou et la tolérance
pour l'immigration légale ce n'est pas
de la compassion
en fait c'est de la cruauté
rôles entre web une femme sur trois est
agressée sexuellement
sur ce long périple vers un art et les
passeurs se servent des enfants migrants
comme des pions afin d'exploiter nos
lois et en arriver à notre territoire
les trafiquants humains et les
trafiquants et de sexe profitent de ces
aires ouvertes de nos frontières et des
différents ports pour faire entrer en
contrebande des milliers de jeunes
femmes et les vendre dans la
prostitution et l' esclavage moderne
des dizaines de milliers de nos
compatriotes innocents sont tués par des
stupéfiants mortel qui traversent la
frontière et inonder nos villes
cela inclut le met l'héroïne la cocaïne
et le fentanyl et c'est dingue de
sauvage le ms 13 existent s'est enraciné
dans au moins une vingtaine d'états
américains et ils ont presque tous
traversé cette frontière méridionale
pas plus tard qu'hier un membre ms-13 a
été pris en détention pour une fusillade
sur une plateforme de métro dans la
ville de new york
nous sommes en train de retirer ses
membres de gagne par milliers mais
jusqu'à ce que nous ayons plus de
sécurité la frontière ils vont continuer
à revenir à re franchir cette frontière
année après année combien d'américains
sont assassinés par des étrangers sans
papiers
j'ai appris à connaître beaucoup de
mères de pères de famille généreuse qui
ont perdu un être cher mais personne ne
doit souffrir cette douleur horrible qui
est la leur ce soit parmi nous il ya des
brebis saut qu'il ya à peine trois
semaines judd et charline les parrains
de debra ont été assassinés dans leur
maison à rhinau levada par un
sans-papier
il avait franchi le cap des années 80 et
ont quatre enfants aux petits enfants et
26 petits enfants soirée un peu de sa
fin également parmi nous ce soir sont la
petite fille que gerald shargel est
l'arrière petite fille mal sinon à
d'abord à ma nation je levais vous s'il
vous plaît peu de gens peuvent
comprendre votre douleur
merci merci de votre présence
our moi je ne pourrais oublier et je me
battre pour préserver la mémoire de
gerald et les charognes coût que cela ne
se reproduise jamais pas une seule vie
américaine de plus devraient être perdus
perdu parce que notre nation m'a pas
réussi à protéger sa frontière
depuis deux ans nous douaniers ont
procédé à 266 1000 arrestations de ces
sans-papiers criminelle et cela inclut
ceux qui ont été accusés ou reconnu
coupable de tout près de saint mais
l'agression trente mille crimes sexuels
et 4000 meurtre nous avons parmi nous ce
soir un de ses héros l'agent spécial des
douanes afd
hernandez
merci quand élevé n'était tout jeune il
est arrivé ici avec sa famille en toute
légalité en partance de la république
dominicaine à l'âge de 8 ans elle
vénérait son papa qui le doute voulait
devenir un agent spécial aujourd'hui il
dirige deux enquêtes sur ce fléau
le trafic sexuel internationale a dit si
je peut m'assurer que ces jeunes filles
puissent obtenir justice je réussis dans
mon travail
grâce au travail d'éleveur et de tous
ses collègues au delà de 300 femmes et
filles ont pu être rescapée de l'horreur
de ce fléau horrible et plus de 1500
trafiquants sadi qui ont été envoyés en
prison
[Applaudissements]
nous allons toujours soutenir les hommes
et les femmes courageux des forces de
l'ordre et je vous promets ici ce soir
que je ne vais jamais abolir nos héros
des forces de l'ordre et des troupes
frontalières et douanières
[Applaudissements]
envoyé au congrès une proposition visant
à mettre fin à la crise sur la frontière
méridionale
il est question des d'humanitaire le
plus de forces de l'ordre
détection des stupéfiants au port la
l'élimination des échappatoires qui
permettent le trafic d'enfants et les
plans pour une nouvelle barrière
physique ou un mur afin de protéger
toutes ces zones entre les ports
d'entrée où les points d'entrée par le
passé la plupart des gens dans ces
salles ont voté pour un mur mais le mur
n'a jamais été construit moi je vais
réussir à le faire construire
[Applaudissements]
c'est une barrière d'acier qui est
intelligente stratégique
on peut voir à travers est non seulement
un mur de béton cette barrière sera
déployé dans les zones identifiées par
les douaniers comme éteint les ont les
plus à risque et ses agents vous diront
que là où les barrières c'est l'aide et
s'érige les traverses où les gens qui
traversent de façon illégale
eh bien ces chiffres chutent sont en
chute libre
[Applaudissements]
il a une certaine époque santiago avait
le plus grand nombre de traversées
illégale au pays
en réaction une barrière très solide a
été érigé cette barrière puissante après
ce que met fin complètement ou traversée
illégale la frontalière d'el paso texas
avec des taux de criminalité violente
très élevé en fait un des taux les plus
élevés du pays
et c'était en fait une ville qui était
parmi les villes les plus dangereuses de
notre pays aujourd'hui
[Musique]
après la construction de la barrière une
barrière vraiment solide
el paso est devenu de nouvelles et plus
sécuritaire ces prix paul pointe à bref
les murs fonctionne et les murs sauve
des vies
ou alors travaillons ensemble trouvons
un compromis arrivons à nous entendre
pour que nous puissions assurer la
sécurité de l'amérique à mesure que nous
travaillons pour défendre la sécurité de
nos concitoyens
il nous faut également assurer le
renouveau économique et que sa cadence
plus s'accélérer il n'y a personne à
profiter davantage d'une économie
effervescente que les femmes qui ont
comblé 58 % des emplois créés l'année
dernière
[Applaudissements]
i want the wall street vous ne deviez
pas faire cela mais merci merci merci
beaucoup
tous les américains et toutes les
américaines peuvent être fiers que nous
avons plus de femmes dans la main
d'oeuvre qu'à tout moment de notre
histoire
[Applaudissements]
attendez ne vous assoyez par mesdames
vous allez bien les muscles arrive
exactement un siècle après que le
congrès ait adopté l'amendement
constitutionnel donnant aux femmes le
droit de voter nous avons également plus
de femmes qui siège au congrès qu'à tout
moment de notre histoire
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien c'est formidable c'est
vraiment bien
félicitations dans le cadre notre
engagement à améliorer les perspectives
d'avenir pour les femmes partout ce
jeudi nous allons lancer la première
initiative gouvernementale se polarisant
sur l'autonomisation économique des
femmes dans les pays en voie de
développement afin de nous inspirer de
notre succès économique incroyable une
priorité semble vraiment fondamental
inversée décennies de ses politiques
commerciales catastrophique
nous avons maintenant exprimer très
clairement la chine qui après des années
d'avoir ciblé nos industries d'avoir
volé notre propriété intellectuelle
le vol d'emplois américains heydari
chasse américaine eh bien c'est fini
cette époque là
c'est pourquoi tout récemment nous avons
imposé des tarifs sur 250 milliards de
dollars de biens chinois et mettant
notre 13 ans reçoit des milliards de
dollars mais je ne veux pas rejeter le
blâme sur la chine d'avoir profité de
nous je rejette le blâme sur nos leaders
et nous représente 1 qui ont permis
cette trahison
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour le
président chi et nous travaillons
maintenant sur nouvelle entente
commerciale avec la chine mais c'est
tentant doit exclure des changements
structurels riel pour mettre fin aux
pratiques commerciales déloyales réduire
notre déficit commercial chronique et
protéger l'emploi américain
[Applaudissements]
une autre grave erreur historique
c'était la catastrophe connue sous son
acronyme l'alena je raconterai les
hommes et les femmes de michigan l'ohio
de pain sylvanie de l'indiana du new
hampshire et bien d'autres états dont
les rêves rang et volé en éclats après
la signature de l'alena
pendant des années les politiciens ont
promis qu'ils allaient négocié
renégocier avoir de meilleurs conscient
mais personne n'avait essayé jusqu'à
maintenant notre nouveaux accords kainda
états unis mexique l'a remplacé l'alena
et va offrir aux travailleurs américains
perspective
jusqu alors rêver j'espère que vous
pourrez adopter cet accord pour que nous
puissons ramener nos emplois
manufacturiers faire élargir
l'agriculture mais ken protéger notre
propriété intellectuelle et nous assurer
qu'un plus grand nombre d'autos son
assemblée jusqu'à la toute fin et
étampes et de ces merveilleux mot
fabriquées aux états unis
ce soir je vous demande également
d'adopter la loi sur la réciprocité
commerciale pour que si jamais un pays
nous impose un tarif inéquitable sur un
produit
nous pouvons et poser le même tarif sur
le même produit qu'ils essaient de nous
vendre
or pour allécher les deux parties
devraient en mesure de s'unir afin de ce
grand projet vise à reconstruire notre
infrastructure qui est en ruine
ailleurs je sais que le congrès a hâte
d'adopter un projet de loi sur
l'infrastructure et j'ai hâte de
travailler avec vous sur un projet de
loi visant à reconstruire et réinvestir
dans l'infrastructure et cela inclut
dans les industries de pointe
ce n'est pas une option mesdames et
messieurs c'est une nécessité
la prochaine grande priorité pour moi et
pour nous tous et tout ça devrait
d'abaisser le coût des soins de santé et
des médicaments prescrits et de protéger
les patients avec des conditions
préexistantes
orange a déjà grâce à mes efforts en
les prix des médicaments ont connu leur
baisse la plus importante à 46 ans
oui mais il nous faut faire davantage
il est inacceptable que des américains
est tellement plus que les gens dans
d'autres pays pour les mêmes médicaments
parfois voire souvent fabriqués à la
même usine
c'est une erreur c'est inacceptable
c'est inéquitable et ensemble il faut le
stopper net
je demande au congrès d'adopter un
projet de loi qui pourra finalement
s'attaquer au problème de cette
transparence des prix et de l'équité
pour les patients américains
il nous faut également exigé des grandes
pharmaceutiques des compagnies
d'assurances des hôpitaux de dévoiler
les vrais prix afin que nous puissions
en arrivait une plus grande concurrence
et faire abaisser les prix de beaucoup
je n'ai aucune influence dans l'histoire
a fait davantage pour faire avancer la
condition humaine que la liberté
américaine nws
depuis quelques années nous avons connu
des progrès remarquables dans le combat
contre le vih sida des percées
scientifiques ont fait apparaître des
solutions à portée de main mon but
javaux demander ou démocrates comme
républicains de s'engager afin
d'éliminer l'épidémie de vih ici 10 ans
sur le territoire national
nous avons tant progressé
ensemble nous allons vaincre le sida à
l'amérique et au delà ce soit j'aimerais
également vous inviter à vous joindre à
moi dans un autre combat un combat
national le combat contre eux le cancer
chez les enfants
johnny aux côtés de magna dans la
galerie publique ce soir on retrouve une
petite fille vraiment courageuse de dix
ans grâce divine
à chaque anniversaire
[Applaudissements]
alors brice chaque anniversaire
depuis il ya eu 4 1 le s a demandé à ses
amis de faire des dons à l'hôpital saint
john
elle ne savait pas qu'un jour elle y
serait patiente et c'est ce qui est
arrivé l'année dernière greece a reçu un
diagnostic de cancer du cerveau
rapidement elle a commencé le traitement
aux rayons x
en même temps elle a pu rallye sa
communauté elle a donc pu recueillir
plus de 15 mille dollars pour ce combat
contre le cancer
green a complété ses traitements à
l'automne dernier qui les médecins les
infirmières l'ont applaudi un jeu
l'adorent y mourir
les larmes aux yeux quand elle a
accroché une affiche qui êtes dernière
journée de chimio
[Applaudissements]
merci gries tu es une source incroyable
d'inspiration pour chacun dans cette
salle merci beaucoup de cancers
pédiatriques nom a vu de nouvelles
thérapies apparaître des décennies en
plus j'avais demandé au congrès pour une
allocation de 500 millions de la soupe
impôts financé cette recherche critique
afin d'aider les parent qui travaille le
temps est venu pour adopter le choix
scolaires pour les enfants américains
je suis également fier d'être le premier
président inclure dans mon budget un
plan pour un régime de congé parental
rémunéré pour que chaque nouveau parrain
est l'occasion de s'attacher à leur
nouveau-né
[Applaudissements]
difficile de s'imaginer plus grand
contraste que cette image magnifique
d'une mère tenant son nouveau né que ce
qu'on a vu depuis quelques jours au mcee
les législateurs à new york qui ont
applaudi de ravissement à l'adoption du
projet de loi qui permettrait un bébé
d'un rat chez aux entrailles de sa mère
à quelques moments à peine avant sa
naissance
ce sont deux bébés merveilleux qui
n'auront jamais la chance de partager
l'amour et le rêve avec le monde et
ensuite nous avons eu ce cas de du
gouverneur de la virginie qui l'a dit
qu'il exécuterait bébé après sa
naissance afin de défendre la dignité de
chaque personne
je demande au congrès d'adopter un
projet de loi afin d'interdire
l'avortement en troisième trimestre des
enfants qui peuvent ressentir la douleur
dans le ventre de leur mère
travaillons ensemble afin de narrer une
culture qui chérit la vie innocente
[Applaudissements]
réaffirmons une vérité fondamentale
tous les enfants nés ou encore à naître
sont façonnés dans l'image sacrée de
dieu dernier volet de mes priorités
j'écris c'est de protéger la sécurité
nationale de l'amérique depuis deux ans
nous avons commencé à rebâtir l'appareil
militaire de l'amérique avec 700
milliards de dollars l'année dernière et
716 milliards de dollars cette année si
nous exigeons également d autres pays
qu'ils paient leur juste part
enfin enfin
voyez jeudi pendant de longues années
les états unis seraient maltraités par
le temps c'était nos amis en fait les
membres de l'otan nous allier et
maintenant nous avons réussi à obtenir
depuis quelques années une augmentation
de 100 milliards de dollars dans les
dépenses de défense dans nos pays alliés
il clamait les possibilités de la tâche
eh bien non c'est fait
dans le cadre de notre reconstruction
militaire ne développe pas un système
antimissile à la fine pointe de la
science grâce à mon gouvernement nous
n'allons jamais nous excuser de faire
avancer les intérêts de l'amérique par
exemple il ya des décennies les états
unis ont conclu retraités avec la russie
selon lequel nous étions prêts à limiter
à réduire nos capacités de mes cellules
pendant que nous avons adhéré à la
lettre la russie a violé les termes les
conditions du traité de façon répétée
cela fait des années que ça dure
c'est pourquoi j'annonce est que les
états unis allaient se retirer de façon
officielle du traité inf sur les forces
nucléaires de portée intermédiaire
[Applaudissements]
nous n'avons vraiment pas le choix
est il possible de négocier un autre
accord a rajouté à la chaîne et d'autres
peut-être ce ne sera pas possible makaka
nous allons dépenser davantage que tous
les autres et cela de loin
d'abord dans le cadre de cette nouvelle
diplomatie audacieuse nous continuons
notre poussée historique pour la paix
sur la péninsule coréenne nous otages
sont revenus chez nous les essais
nucléaires sont choses du passé
il n'y a pas eu de met ses lancers en
plus de 15 mois
si je n'avais pas été élu président des
états unis d'amérique
aujourd'hui en ce moment selon moi nous
serions dans une guerre importante avec
la corée du nord
mouchoirs qu'il reste beaucoup de
travail à abattre mais ma relation avec
kingdom nul est une bonne relation
le présent kim et moi allons nous
rencontrer à nouveau le 27 et le 28
février au vietnam
tori qu'il ya deux semaines les etats
unis ont reconnu de façon officielle le
gouvernement légitime du venezuela et
son nouveau président par intérim
wan wide
we say die valais zoug où le tenant
debout aux côtés du peuple vénézuélien
dans leur quête noble de liberté elle
nous dénonçons la brutalité du régime
maduro dont l'épaule et section sa liste
ont transformé cette nation deux des
plus riches de l'amérique du sud en état
de pauvreté abjecte et de désespoir chez
nous ici aux etats unis
nous sommes alarmés par ses appels
colons l'entente vise à adopter le
socialisme dans notre pays
l'amérique a été fondée sur la liberté
l'indépendance et non la coercition des
gouvernements la domination et la prise
de contrôle
nous sommes nés libres et nous allons
demeurer libre
tonight ce soir nous revenons nous
renouvelons cette détermination que
l'amérique ne deviendra jamais un pays
socialiste
[Applaudissements]
one of the most complexe ce challenger
série de défis les plus complexes que
l'on doit relever ses taux moyen orient
notre approche se fonde sur des
principes sur le réalisme fondée sur des
principes et non des tv discréditer qui
n'ont rien donné pendant des décennies
qu'on a vu sans progrès c'est pour cela
que mon gouvernement reconnu la capitale
reyel d'israël et que nous avons
fièrement ouvert l'ambassade américaine
à jérusalem
hao bref jobs smooth da courageux se
battent au moyen orient pour tout près
de 19 ans en afghanistan en irak tout
près de 7000 héros américains ont
sacrifié leur vie plus de 5 en 2000
américains ont été gravement blessées et
nous avons dépensé plus de 7 billions de
dollars au moyen orient à faire la
guerre à titre de candidat à la
présidentielle j'ai promis une nouvelle
approche
les grandes nations ne s'embourbe pas
dans les guerres sans fin
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pris le pouvoir
esch contrôler plus de vingt mille
milles carrés en irak et un série cela
ne fait que deux ans de cela
aujourd'hui nous avons libéré presque
tout le territoire de l'emprise de ces
sanguinaires de ces monstres aujourd'hui
travaillant avec nos alliés ou visant à
détruire les vestiges de dèche les
grands enfants que nous puissions offrir
à nos soldats acclamations de bienvenue
chez nous j'ai également accélérer les
négociations visant à m'arrivait un
règlement politique en afghanistan
le côté adverse est également très
content de se retrouver à la table de
négociation nous troupes ont fait preuve
de vaillance sans les mettait et grâce à
leur courage
nous sommes maintenant en train de
poursuivre une solution politique à ce
conflit prolongé
et l'afghanistan mon roman chez est en
pourparlers constructifs avec un certain
nombre de groupes afghans et cela inclut
les talibans à mesure que nous
progressons dans ces négociations
nous serons mais nous serons en mesure
de réduire la présence de nos troupes et
de polariser notre attention sur la
lutte contre le terrorisme et c'est ce
que nous avons l'intention de faire
nous ne savons pas encore si nous
parviendrons à nous entendre
mais nous savons qu après deux décennies
de guerre l'heure est venue d'essayer au
moins ils en arriver à la paix l'autre
côté le côté adverse désir la même chose
le temps est arrivé
moreau fender dessus tout les amis comme
les ennemis ne doivent jamais douté la
puissance de notre nation et de notre
volonté à défendre notre peuple
il a 18 ans de violence se sont attaqués
ou iss col il le mois dernier les forces
américaines ont tué un des chefs de cet
attentat
nous avons le grand honneur d'être en
présence de tant mme aubry dont le fils
le marin craig web relie cette heure
était temps les 17 marins qu'on a perdu
tragiquement à bord de ce navire
tom nous vous promettons de nous
rappeler toujours les héros du haut
escaut
merci
[Applaudissements]
agi de façon décisive pour affronter le
parrain étatique de premier plan d'eau
terreur et il est question du régime
radical de terrain c'est un régime
radical
ce sont vraiment de mauvais acteurs j'ai
pour s'assurer que ce dictatures
corrompues ne puisse jamais mettre le
grappin sur des armes nucléaires j'ai
retiré les états unis de cet accord sur
le nucléaire iranien cet accord
désastreux
pauline poids l'automne dernier nous
avons mis en place les sanctions les
plus sévères jamais apposé sur un pays
dans l'histoire d'amérique
nous n'allons pas détourner notre regard
d'un régime qui chante mort à l'amérique
et qui menace le peuple juif de génocide
il ne faut jamais ignoré ce vil poison
qu'est l'antisémitisme ou ceux qui
propagent ces méfaits avec une seule
voix il nous faut affronter cette haine
partout et à chaque fois qu'elle surgit
il ya quelques mois on the american de
foi juive était assassiné dans une
attaque
ainsi ces mythes et dans le seigneur
gogh tree of life ou arbre de la vie à
pittsburgh
l'officier thématique est arrivée en
courant et a été arrêté par sept coups
de feu
poursuivant le tueur il vient de sortir
de sa deuxième opération chirurgicale il
n'aura bien d'autres mais il s'est
déplacé pour être parmi nous ce soir à
jean maxime s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
merci nous sommes reconnaissants pour
l'éternité
ce soir nous avons également parmi nous
un survivant de pittsburgh
monsieur joe dassin met il est arrivé à
la synagogue
au moment du début de la fusée al mais
non seulement at il pu échapper à la
mort
à l'automne dernier il ya plus de 70 ans
il a survécu de justesse au camp de
concentration des nazis aujourd'hui il
termine sa 81e année c'est son
anniversaire aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
et
e
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
il ne le ferait pas pour moi duda tu
sais je dois nous dit qu'il se rappelle
encore le moment précis il ya tout près
de 75 ans après dix mois dans un camp de
concentration
quand lui et sa famille étaient placés
dans un train et on leur dit qu'ils se
rendent à un autre 15 tout à coup le
train s'est arrêté et c'était vraiment
violent comme choc un soldat est apparue
la famille de judas se préparait au pire
et ensuite son père a crié de joie
ce sont les américains ce sont les
américains
[Applaudissements]
merci un autre survivant de la shoah est
parmi nous ce soir
joshua kaufen il était prisonnier à
dacca au un camp de concentration
ils se rappellent ils regardent à
travers un petit trou dans un mur
en fait la paroi d'un wagon à bétail
quand les américains sont arrivés en
char d'assaut pour moi jean choix se
rappelle les soldats américains c'était
la preuve que dieu existe est elles sont
arrivées du ciel ils sont venus du ciel
j'ai commencé ce soir on en aura trois
soldats qui se sont battus
le 6 juin mais ça 44 lors de la seconde
guerre mondiale l'un d'entre eux était
une tactique mais l'histoire d'hermann
est plus longue
une année après son arrivée sur les
plages à l'hormadi hermann est un des
seuls d'un américain qui a aidé à
libérer le candidat chaos
et vous vous êtes des américains qui
sont venus à la rescousse de joshua de
cet enfer sur terre
il ya tout pas de 75 ans plus tard on
met les deux choix sont ensemble dans la
galerie publique ce soir à 6,1 à côté de
l'autre ici dans le foyer de la liberté
américaine a mené déjà choix votre
présence ici est un honneur pour nous
merci beaucoup de votre présence
[Applaudissements]
vaincus merci quand les soldats
américains sont partis sous ces cieux
sombre pour traverser la manche
à l'aube du 6 juin 1944 il était tout
jeune il avait 18 19 ans dans leurs
embarcations fragile en direction de
cette bataille historique une des
batailles et les plus célèbres dans
l'histoire de la guerre il ne savait pas
s'il allait survivre une heure il ne
savait pas s'il allait vieillir mais il
savait que l'amérique devait absolument
l'emporter lors causse
c'était notre nation et des générations
encore à naître
pourquoi l'ont ils fait ils l'ont fait
pour l'amérique
ils l'ont fait pour nous tout ce qui est
suivi depuis notre triomphe contre le
communisme nous grandes enjambées en
science n'est dans les découvertes
diverses notre progrès sans égale vers
l'égalité la justice
tout cela possible grâce au sang grâce
au courage grâce aux larmes gras chaud
vision de ces américains qui nous
précèdent sens et à ceux capitole penser
à cette assemblée ou les députés et les
sénateurs avant vous ont voté pour
mettre fin à l esclavage construire les
autoroutes les chemins de fer et de
verre du fascisme d'en arriver aux
droits civiques de mettre fin aux
empires maléfique et si ce soir nous
avons des l'élite législateur de partout
dans cette république magnifique et la
nôtre vous êtes arrivé des rivages
rocheux du maine
des pics volcaniques d'hawaï et des
forêts enneigées douze concerts et les
déserts rouge de l'arizona des fermes
verte du kentucky et des plages dorées
de la californie ensemble nous
représentons la nation la plus
extraordinaire de toute l'histoire qu'un
lot nous faire de ce moment
comment vont-ils se rappeler de nous je
demande aux hommes et aux femmes de ce
congrès
regardez ces possibilités qui se
présentent à nous nous réalisations les
plus enivrante nous attendent nous
dessiner les plus ravissantes nous
attendent nous plus grandes victoires
nous attendent nous n'avons même pas
encore commencé à rêver il nous faut
choisir si nous voulons être définies
par nos différences ou si nous avons
l'audace de les transcender
il nous faut choisir si nous allons
gaspiller notre héritage magnifique ou
si nous allons déclarer fièrement que
nous sommes américains nous réussissons
ce qui est incroyable
nous allons au défi de l'est possible
nous avons en nous la conquête de
l'inconnu c'est le moment
le moment est venu de revitaliser
l'imaginaire américain
le moment est venu de cette audace
nécessaire pour le sommet le plus élevé
est de chercher l'étoile la plus
brillante
le temps est venu de renouveler
y ait de l'amour de la loyauté et de
souvenirs qui nous unissent comme
citoyen comme voisins comme patriote
c'est notre avenir c'est notre destin
et c'est notre choix personnel et
collectif
je vous demande de choisir la grandeur
quelles que soient les épreuves devant
nous quelles que soient les défis à
relever
il nous faut avancer ensemble
il nous faut garder l'amérique dans nos
coeurs avant tout il nous faut garder la
flamme de la liberté dans l'eau âmes
elle nous faut toujours maintenir la foi
dans le dessein de l'amérique qu'une
nation sous dieu doit être la promesse
et l'espoir et la lumière et la gloire
parmi toutes les nations du monde
merci que dieu vous bénisse et que dieu
bénisse l'amérique merci
c'était le deuxième discours de sur
l'état de l'union du président dans
notre chambre
un discours faut peut-être le passionné
assez sobre qui faisait un grand appel à
l'unité à la grandeur de l'amérique
c'était un peu son thème conducteur de
ceux de ce discours misant sur une
économie forte et sur la nécessaire
protection des américains à travers à
travers son discours encore une fois sur
l'immigration illégale et le mur des
bons moments des moments moins bond on
appelle aussi donc à cette unité mais un
discours parsemé d'exemple à caractère
très humain on pense à la réforme la
justice criminelle java savoir de vous
car entre mon agent je pense que c'est
déjà avec nous à voir chez nous tout
d'abord karine qu'est ce que vous
retenez sans s'élevant de ce discours
en fait moi j'ai trouvé catch up avait
réussi à contrôler l'essentiel de ses
tics
il avait réussi à garder un ton posé par
le discours mielleux mais je trouve
qu'il a vraiment mis les démocrates et
sur la défensive avec ce discours leur
disant moi je vous tends la main je
trouve des points de convergence dans
nos politiques notamment sur la santé
par exemple le donné plusieurs exemples
je dis qu'il faut à ce cas on le voit
serrer la main jusqu'à 20 a justement il
aurait été question d'avoir pu main dans
l'économie et donc quelques points de
convergence et il a appelé à l'unité
alors autrement dit si les démocrates
n'arrivent pas à s'entendre avec lui ce
sera de leur faut tu leur être compromis
john puisque votez-vous essentiellement
fait d'accord que le réussis sur le
temps dans son ensemble c'est clair
qu'ils étaient très partisan sur le mur
partisans sur les questions dans kate
son neveu de prison pour avoir des
points phares tantôt mais je pense que
c'était celle aux états unis que le sco
de lignum habituellement fait gagner des
points dans les sondages au président et
je pense que monsieur tron n'a pas perdu
des points
il y avait vraiment besoin de ça y est
on a senti que les républicains dans la
salle voulait l'encourager parce que les
républicains dans la salle ont eu quatre
cinq mois de mauvaises nouvelles
perdre la chambre et le choc dans ces
cas que tous les sondages indiquaient
leur pelouse et a gagné haut la main
donc dans un sens il serrait shell
échapper un d'un peu mais on voit quand
même que monsieur trompe on va devoir
être assez combatif dans la plaie
discours se veut sans j'ai aussi eu son
mur et encore c'est un jeu et ça marche
et que peut-être les démocrates
pourraient pas changé mais le problème
que je sens c'est que les démocrates on
pas réussi à imposer même dans leur
victoire de l'otan de passer à imposer
une vision d'une nouvelle année pays et
ça c'est dangereux
la dernière fois qu'un président à
findus qu'au delà des nations à peu près
à 42 40 % dans les sondages
c'était briguen qui est à sa deuxième
année comme président pierre haïk de
l'intérieur avait dans 49 états donc
l'économie le trad économies même si
exagéré j'ai des chiffres il ya déjà des
facs csaky qui démontrent qu'ils
exagèrent les chefs les fadas mais on
peut pas nier que cette économie là
fonctionne il ya deux éléments de
important tenir compte des
infrastructures et la chine et un autre
en parle après la pause à vous c'est pas
la pause on va retrouver christian
latreille ont pas réentendre des moments
forts de ce fruit des moments émouvants
les moments intéressants
d'émouvants de moments de grande
unanimité alors mesdames messieurs
rester avec nous on va poursuivre après
la pause à tous
[Musique]
cour de l'état de l'union dans notre
chambre etait-il très présidentiel
est-ce que trump gagne des points ce
soir ce qui lance au fond sa campagne
présidentielle pour 2020 christian à
washington qu'est ce que vous aimez les
bons soirs à quelques rebonds soir
qu'est ce que vous avez retenu vous de
ce discours là vous at il étonné soit
par le ton par les priorités qu'il
établit bien écoutez il ya toujours deux
dans deux champs penche lui devant ses
partisans à celui en conférence de
presse que de la difficulté à se
contrôler et qui est très émotif qui
lancent des flèches à tout le monde
qu'ils s'attaquent à tout le monde et
dans notre chambre qu'on a vu ce soir
parce que monsieur ne chante pas été les
souffleurs devant lui lorsqu'il un texte
à lire il est en général assez bon et ce
soir c'est ce qu'on a senti il était en
maîtrise
il était un américain parmi tant
d'autres et il a vraiment tendu la main
il a tenter de panser les plaies de
faire en sorte que les vieilles
querelles se termine c'est le message du
moins qui est il qu'il a lancé et c'est
le même message qu'il avait lancé
l'année dernière
mais vous savez c'est un peu le problème
avec monsieur de chaume ça ne dure
jamais très longtemps
on ne sait pas dans quelques heures dans
quelques jours quel tweet va survenir
comment va-t-il s'attaquer à cet
adversaire est probablement profond de
lui-même et qu' il aimerait bien faire
en sorte de pouvoir travailler avec les
démocrates éventuellement pour faire
avancer les états unis mais sera-t-il
l'homme de la situation sera t-il le
président justement capable de faire en
sorte qu' il puisse travailler avec
madame pelossi et son équipe au congrès
il n'a plus vraiment le choix en ce
moment s'il veut voter un programme
d'infrastructures baisser le prix des
médicaments etc chez terra il va devoir
effectivement continuer cette politique
de la main tendue mais jusqu'à quand ça
valorise c'est surtout le propre avec
une date butoir du 15 février on verra
s'il va menacer israël va parler de
paralysie mais il parlait beaucoup de
son mur mais en même temps tend la main
aux démocrates de christian mais avec
une sorte de mise en garde
arrêtez ces enquêtes ridicule personnes
à la chambre des représentants parce
qu'on sait que l'argent des
représentants majoritaires lance déjà
des enquêtes et veut
paris - des super nanas pour forcer les
témoignages de certaines personnes
cliquent d'entourage à monsieur thuram
oui et ça les démocrates n'ont pas
l'intention de lâcher le morceau à ce
niveau là il veut lanka était surtout
tout ce qui concerne monsieur choï
évidemment lorsque monsieur pour tout
homme parlait dans quatre ridicule et de
viser particulièrement dans quête maurer
qu'il qualifie sans cesse de chasse aux
sorcières monsieur morin qui n'a
toujours pas rendu public son rapport
un rapport qui se fait attendre qu'ils
devraient en principe être rédigé ou
terminés d'être rédigé au cours des
prochaines semaines des prochains mois
et qui pourrait faire très mal et être
un point tournant de la présidence tram
alors monsieur 30 ne pas manquer
l'occasion ce soir de dire à des
millions d'américains que si l'amérique
veut continuer sur cette lancée
si l'amérique veut continuer d'avoir une
économie en croissance d'être prospère
il faut cesser ces querelles il faut
cesser ce sens qu'elle et ses enquêtes
en ce moment le vise lui font très mal
politiquement et pourrait lui faire très
mal également pour sa réélection en vain
parce qu'encore aujourd'hui d'un prenait
qui aurait enquête très approfondie sur
le comité de son investiture
mon argent dépensé l'origine de l'argent
le plus peu à plusieurs personnes vont
être contraintes de répondre à plusieurs
questions alors cette astuce vous laisse
filer au téléjournal avec avec céline
mais il est important que ça vous savez
il ya le discours ce soir mais dans les
heures qui viennent de demain matin ça
va être les fameux tweets et
et que le ton qu'il va emprunter dès
demain pour poursuivre donc ses
intentions merci christian bonne soirée
au bord de ce mois alors johnny car il
n'est donc les lions peut-être un
écouter quelques extraits parce que la
question du mur n'est ce pas est très
très important de toujours une non
j'aime morts portent à court terme à
court terme oui parce qu'alors web d'un
extrait de son discours ses choix
stratégiques
c'est une barrière d'acier qui est
intelligente stratégique
on peut voir à travers est non seulement
un mur de béton cette barrière sera
déployé dans les zones identifiées par
les douaniers comme éteint les ont les
plus à risque et ses agents vous diront
que là où les barrières célèbre et
s'érige les traverses où les gens
traversent de façon illégale
eh bien ces chiffres chutent sont en
chute libre
alors il a il a voulu dire dans le fond
que le mur mais qu'à l'abri les
américains puisque c'est une absolue
nécessité
oui contredit par les chefs et les
chiffres et les enquêtes et les enquêtes
et et toutes les données vont en sens
contraire les murs ne fonctionne pas
parce que plein façon de les contourner
et simplement de la criminalité en fait
sacrer tous les problèmes que ça soit
évité et il le sait les américains le
savent
hélas ce qui est intéressant et on a vu
un appel aussi sourire derrière lui
parce qu'il a finalement donné plusieurs
définitions 10 ans fait le comme vous
voulez qu'on voit à travers que ce soit
en béton
peu importe en autant qu'ils aient
quelque chose que je peux appeler un mur
pour dire à mes partisans regardez j'ai
réellement en plus de cet extrait là il
y avait toute la déclinaison des dangers
que courent les amis de tous les crimes
commis tout soit déjà de plusieurs mais
américains font une épreuve des faits et
ils passent pas le test se trame
historique et exagère évidemment il
déforme les données donc on est dans une
situation qui est voulu faire l'inde
allié plaidoirie ya pas mentionné
urgence nationale
donc il est clair qui sait que sur sa
base c'est-à-dire sont ces
représentations le public n soit chambre
ou au sénat sont pas en faveur de nos
chances nationale parce que si que les
précédents de quelque chose qui n'est
pas vraiment une vraie crise quand un
président démocrate voilà tout pouvoir
et peut utiliser ce précédent à la peau
des législations internes des
changements climatiques ou le contrôle
des armes
donc il est républicain on part du
précédent et je pense que 36 points là
il ya baissé le ton nom kennedy ce qui
va faire pour le 15 février qu'elle va
être là vu sa marge de négociation ci
provoque un autre choc dans leurs
employés dans des saisons
il est clair que les gains qui vont
refaire ce soir pour nous at il concédé
qu'elle fait des gains ils voient des
peuples alors on peut être écouté un
autre extrait celui ci est ce que c'est
sur la plage prend la place des femmes
parce que c'est un point de consensus
ailleurs on n'a jamais vu autant de
femmes au congrès américain puis c'est
un moment d'unité de novation on écoute
tous les américains et toutes les
américaines peuvent être fiers que nous
aurons plus de femmes dans la main
d'oeuvre quatum en main de notre
histoire
[Applaudissements]
attendez ne vous assoyez par mesdames
vous allez bien les muscles arrive
exactement un siècle la après que le
congrès ait adopté l'amendement
constitutionnel donnant aux femmes le
droit de voter nous avons également plus
de femmes qui siège au congrès qu'à tout
moment de notre histoire
[Applaudissements]
alors plus de femmes se remettre dans
l'histoire des femmes vêtues de blanc
pourra plus parce que ce cinquième
anniversaire du droit de vote à leurs
sous c'est une manière intéressante
parce que vous vendre la part d'autres
femmes de tendre la main encore une fois
au débarrasser de bonne guerre parce
qu'il a perdu à cause de ses 240
personnes qui ont été élus à la chambre
des représentants en plus il reconnaît
que ces femmes là arrivent massivement
et il leur a tendu la main aux 6es de
différentes façons par ce qu'il a
proposé des mesures qui intéressent les
femmes notamment sur la sécurité des
femmes il a également parlé de congé
parental par exemple en annonçant non ça
n'existe pas ça n'existe pas et à moins
d'avoir des assurances privées
je me vois la mémé c'est c'est une
première alors il est à peu près temps
diront 5e chez cécile 24 chambres qui
possède depuis depuis très longtemps et
là il annonce donc cette ce sont des
mesures qui vont qui vont aider beaucoup
de femmes en particulier
alors je pense que c'est un des rares
moments assemblage de vue de façon très
claire et sur la justice criminelle
il est très bien dit d'aller à ce moment
là ça me permettra le puisque avantage
juste à côté de votre question qu'il y
ait 100 ce qui sert essentiellement que
la construction ce discours a quand même
été très habile il ya vraiment il a fait
ces attaques partisanes compter les
démocrates mais y'a pus verrez sur la
question des femmes et aussi des gens
qui
ça fait maintenant 75 ans depuis la fin
de la deuxième guerre mondiale
les débarquements et les personnes qui
étaient dans la
l'audience car sa carrière l'émotion en
plus de ça les gêne c'est la jeune fille
qui avait pour la question du cancer
j'ai saisi d'un projet qui va de
l'argent pour lutter contre le cancer
pour les enfants tout cas ton m ensemble
on voit qui en avait pour tout le monde
ce colosse si une femme monsieur dans
une semaine ils vont avoir des faits je
pense que les gens vont être assez bien
soin qu'il fallait subi personnes sont
sa popularité d'un coup ou comme vous
avez dit entouré tweet demain matin et
puis de ce sens je veux revenir sur le
cancer de recueillir des fonds avant
même d'être reine de son cancer du
cerveau et lui l'annoncé d'un programme
de 500 millions sur 10 ans pour le
cancer chez les enfants si c'est quand
même des mesures importantes ça puisse
avoir bien accueilli je crois que durant
entre le faire le fan espérait le
congrès beaucoup de ces discours de
l'union douane passer des grandes listes
d'épicerie et quand on fait le décompte
en soutenant un ou deux ans plus tard
lorsqu'ils ont réussi la bd et d'écoles
les pourcentages mais sur la santé
partenaires et ainsi de protéger les
fameux contrats existants protéger mais
en même temps c'est très habile parce
que il se dit si je veux avoir le mur je
dois donner quelque chose au démarrage
bien écoutez c'est donnant donnant cette
affaire alors il a mis plusieurs
éléments alors qu'elle et les démocrates
vont avoir de la peine à laisser aller
dans les négociations alors c'est pas
fini on va en parler
john et qu'elle apposerait son veto en
mai sur cette émission spéciale sur le
deuxième discours de l'union de donald
trump sur le thème de la grandeur de
l'amérique se poursuite soit après la
pause reste avec nous
[Musique]
j'annonçais que les états unis allaient
se retirer de façon officielle du traité
inf sur les forces nucléaires de portée
intermédiaire
[Applaudissements]
nous n'avons vraiment pas le choix
est il possible de négocier un autre
accord à rajoutant la chine et d'autres
peut-être ce ne sera pas possible
ma quelqu'un nous allons dépenser
davantage que tous les autres et cela de
loin alors ce que donneront vient de
relancer la course aux armements
john qu'est ce que vous en pensez
d'abord vous êtes de conservation de
choses mais nous allons dépenser plus
sur autre chose ça prend des budgets oui
c'est inquiétant parce que ça donne
l'impression qu'a posté gic il ce récit
est depuis monsieur poutine s'est
resserrée aussi et en même temps les
négociations pour le libre échange avec
la chaîne qui fait consensus en terme de
ces objectifs pour amener des
changements dans la façon que la chine
fera juge avec les états unis donc il se
deux fronts se demande c'est quoi la
statégie est ce qu'un départ est grand
plus important que l'autre ce que la
chine va être prêt à négocier un traité
pour limiter les armements et le libre
échange en même temps ça paraît très
compliqué et c'est ça qui était là grand
classique la fin de semaine passée quand
je me suis trompé
c'est qu'ils posent des gestes et on
al'impression ceux qui consultent pas
les gens près de lui
je convaincu que les forces armées ont
pas été vraiment ou dégradés commandons
pour était vraiment dans le coup même
chose avec ces commentaires se doper et
d'autres situations comme haïti ce midi
que les tests avec qui sonna la fin
lundi à kerbala
mais c'est toi le continent c'est parce
que le consensus des mélodies parler
ciel lorsqu'il a été question de l'iran
et de déchirer l'accord avec l'iran
belle et le public et saisi les siens
mais encore c'est celle au stade nantais
dans la partie d'un concept est les gens
faisaient super m'étais encore un
anglicisme le cheerleading monsieur tron
sur ces questions là parce que le fonds
d'aidé public et pia il ya une motion il
est mentionné au tout début d'émission
ce soir et une motion qui était passé au
sénat et qui était interdit par le
leader mais je me croyais dans le public
est sur la position du de lettres est
précipité d'afghanistan et de la syrie
donc s'il n'y a pas un consensus sur
l'afghanistan y a mentionné qu est la
paix s'impose et maintenant après 18 ans
et laisser la place aux talibans ça fait
ça fait pas mal d'années qu'on essaie de
négocier avec les talibans avec plus ou
moins de succès on le voit bien et on
comprend que les troupes américaines
sont fatigués on comprend que sur le
terrain y est pour beaucoup d'avancées
concrètes
mais ce qu'il faut comprendre de tout de
tout ces gestes-là c'est que le
leadership américain dans le monde ne
peut pas s'exprimer uniquement par une
augmentation des budgets militaires
c'est un leadership politique lucky qui
disparaît justement en sortant des
accords sont en train de négocier à la
pièce est acquise alliés sur l'otan
comme il a fait ce soir le jour on les a
forcés à dar médecins 5 milliard faut
faire un allié lycée est lié et il perd
le tout dit moral quand il se le dise
tout sauf d'antan donc pas parler de
l'entraînement ce soir mais c'est mon
nom quand on parle de tout c'est d'être
laid et avec la critique des élites à ce
que le mont sainte anne et d'afghanistan
j'ai lu l'historial de new york qui est
réel et tout l'éditorial new york dans
le secteur sorti de là bas pourquoi
qu'on était là 18 ans on va donner aux
talibans la possibilité de continuer que
ce qu'ils ont fait à 20 la gamme les
amène à parler du venezuela et du
socialisme parce que d'enfants ya enfin
un exil
exercer son leadership pour contrer le
socialisme les états ne seront jamais
socialiste est au fond le venezuela est
un bel exemple
le socialisme qu'il faut vaincre c'est
la raison pour laquelle les
interviennent et là il ya eu consensus
les consensus en occident le sueur sur
la situation au venezuela mais ça lui a
vraiment servi de tremplin pour faire
une petite pique à l'endroit des
démocrates les plus jeunes démocrates de
boeny centers du couple assure lui ici
aux etats unis
nous sommes alarmés par ses appels
colons l'entente vise à adopter le
socialisme dans notre pays
l'amérique a été fondée sur la liberté
l'indépendance et non la coercition des
gouvernements la domination et la prise
de contrôle
nous sommes nés libres et nous allons
demeurer les bras
tonight ce soit nous revenons au loup
renouvelons cette détermination que
l'amérique ne deviendra jamais un pays
socialiste
alors ça vise beaucoup de monde ici là
vous savez les démocrates le mot social
et c'est l'amour résistance qui étudie
dès le départ ces décès et des cd m on
serait cédée synonyme pour les
démocrates
donc au bout des listes a quasiment
lycées de la chose tellement les gens
calmes et la retourner après la fin de
soirée le rive en arrivons à lire de ça
mais me trompe peut-être aller et a plus
de seuil est ce que c'est un produit à
lunegarde majeur yale il attend lit et a
supervisé entendre que j'allais des
choses qui sont des armes aux questions
de la jussie vraiment trop vietnam sont
en un mot il est très peu de substance
et c'est à peine si étrangère c'est des
choses qu'on savait déjà aussi par yann
on n'a pas appris grand chose de nouveau
sauf peut-être certains noms de congé
parental et des petites mesures qui vont
lui permettre de gagner des points dans
l'opinion publique comme le disait déjà
le sourire mais peut-être ce soir parce
qu'il y avait tellement 4,5 d'animaux
que c'était vraiment la déchéance
je souris l'immeuble sur un seul mot sur
le canada se passant dans l'extrait ci
on entend les deux on ne put à l'écouté
les pousser à la situation n'y a pas de
choix parce que et sur ce point là on
attendait avec une notification si on
est des gens qui ont vu puis quand il se
laisse cette entente la salle aient été
démocrates parce que ce point l'on peut
pas être mais le le cueillir fait la
pression pour la ratification qui
appelait l'alena original
as des as en face à sela les superlatifs
melaky une entente on a tout état de
droit ça doit être signé en somme toute
un discours somme un bon discours parce
que c'est un bon discours et laval appel
de faire appel à la deuxième guerre
mondiale et apollo 11 qui sont
probablement les deux événements libre
rassembleur de ces dernières dès lors il
semble justement donner le temps à ce
discours là et c'était un discours à
saveur électoraliste ou s'il faut pas
l'oublier
jusqu'où que qui était bien construit
dans son ensemble on y construit bien
écrit parce qu il le mieux livrer
puisqu'il est tendance des fois malgré
six coups même si tel cas les prendre
comme maclean's est des fois il est il a
pas bien livrer les données que fait
durant le show digne a commencé à
diriger des gens comme le chantait le
vétéran comme ça se sauver les meubles
sociaux pour le risque et l'autre on va
reparler encore longtemps
merci messieurs merci beaucoup d'avoir
suivi cette émission est spécial sur le
discours de l'union
vous allez retrouver à notre antenne
demain pour la journée également de
longs extraits de ce discours et de son
impact très bonnes fêtes soirée notre
antenne et à demain 19h pour 24 mois
sans pouvoir
[Musique]
ans